the Marge is here full pigtails and all
pigtails in her glory we're giving us
the full fantasy today yes let's get
right into it because we've right Jesus
for what's coming up you get to cross a
housewives milestone for housewives this
would be wine you get to throw a drink
in someone's face oh so good it felt so
good I didn't break a glass but I threw
a drink it's good that's a separate bed
just breaking a glass but I think some
glasses get broken they do after the
drink throw it was such a powerful way
because you know I don't drink alcohol
so I had to take Dolores is drink and I
had to take her red wine and just it
went across the table so effortlessly
and Teresa was wearing white and didn't
even get it on her it only got on
Danielle it was just so artfully - I was
so proud of myself at the end of it
couldn't have gone better for you yeah
it was like magnificent what pushes you
to that moment I could take insults I
could take a lot but she was pushing
pushing I don't see your children
anywhere you don't even know my kids
around you I was like you know what you
need to cool off you're just being an
ass you're saying something purposely to
hurt me I'm gonna put you in your place
got it and you said it felt good it felt
good I do it again
what does Danielle say to you after you
throw a drink on her she called me every
name in the book every slur everything
possible should do she wanted she tried
to break a glass on my head she threw it
but they caught her security had caught
her what is the aftermath of that moment
look like a scene out of The Godfather
because I like just leave it I like go
up this big marble staircase with my
flowing dress she's like a lobster in a
pot like arms flailing securities to
come but glasses start breaking
screaming it was insane
you guys are wrong give me Melissa
Melissa a shock that she gets this
evening never guessed like that she was
livid why does she get to that point you
know a glass breaks just like shamans
your throat lesson almost cut me and
Jennifer cracks the glass and and system
on say you know you know if I broke a
glass that you know if I was gonna cut
you like what is that about that was
like a threatened Melissa's like oh no
you didn't do that to me leaving that
trip I could imagine people were not on
good terms we left that trip we weren't
talking we were undifferenced
flights we didn't want to speak to each
other everybody was like I'm outta here
have you had to sum up the rest of this
season with just one word explosive okay
the rest of the seasons explosive there
is a scene of you pushing Marty in a
pool mm-hmm I think you know he needs
cool off like his wife did earlier it's
just it gets very heated and I do want
to do if my ride to the points he was
never a bad guy but I think can hear
certain people getting your head and
Marty his behavior really went down the
longer he stayed with Danielle but we
know where that's gone at this point now
there were some reports that Marty was
then living with you and Joe can you
clear that oh yes I can totally clear
that up it is not true
not even close to true he was not at my
house he wasn't staying at my house he
has not showed up at my house he's
actually still living with Danielle